Тетяна долучилася до добровольчого батальйону "Карпатська Січ" 24-го лютого.
Нині жінка служить у різних місцях на передовій. Видача єдиного комплекту військової форми
стала для військовослужбовиці неприємним сюрпризом.
І потім, коли вже наш батальйон легалізувався, увійшов до лав Збройних сил України,
видають форму пʼятдесят восьмого розміру.
Форму, чоловічі труси XXL.
Берці видали сорок другого розміру.
Термобілизну видали так само.
Нині в українській армії служить понад 38000 жінок.
Це одна з найбільших часток жінок у збройних силах у світі.
Однак українські солдатки масово скаржаться на відсутність форм з їхніми розмірами,
жіночих засобів гігієни, а також на надважкі шоломи.
Мене добила білизна. Це от я прям отримаю, думаю, форму…
Нічого… Перешию. І мені видають чоловічі труси. Просто…
Думаєш, що вже можна було б закупити, потурбуватись…
Шкарпетки, зимові шкарпетки, термобілизна
теж великого розміру.
Це не жіноча форма. Вона не дуже зручна, тому що вона не ергономічна, тут низька посадка,
і  насправді, не дуже зручно носити кобуру з пістолетом.
Про верх я взагалі мовчу.
Я, наприклад, зараз одягнена в чоловічу сорочку, тому що вона зручніша, але вона все одно велика.
Маргарита Рівчаченко вступила в Київську тероборону в перший день повномасштабного вторгнення Росії.
На своїх чергуваннях жінка щоразу відчувала незручність, спричинену військовою формою.
Піксельна просто... Я в ній тонула, і там у перші місяці, коли було холодно, я ходила, як пампушка.
У мене форма була більше, ніж я, автомат більше, ніж я.
Тобто дуже незручно рухатися у великому одязі.
Ти не можеш ні нормально тримати зброю, ні щось робити.
Якщо Тетяна ушивала видану форму, то Маргарита купила собі другий комплект вже її розміру.
Жінка оплачувала все з власної кишені, і зазначає, що задоволення було не з дешевих.
Ну дивіться, наприклад, одні штани коштують дві з половиною тисячі гривень, ентаківські.
Кожна футболках - це п'ятсот-шістсот гривень.
Плюс це футболка, наприклад, поло.
Окремо ти купуєш собі білизну. Далі більше: спеціальні топи,
які, наприклад, втягують ті ж груди.
Я собі купляла спеціальний спортивний топ, тому що бігати
в бронежилеті і просто, у принципі,
займатися фізичними навантаженнями, ти не можеш
у гарній мереживній білизні.
Як часто це буває в Україні - там, де держава не може впоратися самостійно, на поміч приходять волонтери.
Проєкт "Приміряй її берці" допомагає жінкам,
які служать, з військовою формою, взуттям,
засобами гігієни, бронежилетами і навіть шоломами.
Ось наша форма. Та, що ми кажемо "унісекс". "Стрейтч",
ось так вона виглядає. Це "убекс". І це брюки.
Військову форму "унісекс" і берці волонтери
закуповують в Туреччині.
Хоча у планах відшивати одяг в Україні. На думку Ксенії,
немає комплектів малих розмірів,
тому що держава не очікувала такого різкого
збільшення кількості жінок в армії.
Волонтерка вірить, що з часом міноборони
вирішить цю проблему.
Але вже зараз команда Ксенії робить все, щоб
забезпечити якомога більше жінок формою.
Справа йде про безпеку. Тому що великі штани
можуть перечепитися одна об іншу.
І солдатка на полі бою може в буквальному сенсі впасти.
Це може бути небезпечно для неї, це може бути
небезпечно для всього батальйону.
Для жінок на передовій волонтери також закуповують
шведські плити для бронежилетів.
Держава видає плити мінімум 4,2 кілограми. Це найлегші.
Зазвичай це 5-6. 6 кілограмів одна плита.
Тобто уявіть собі. Їх дві - це 12 кілограмів.
А ще рюкзак парамедика наповнений.
Не порожній. А ще аптечка, ще каска.
А ти парамедик і тягнеш чоловіка, який в амуніції. Це суперважко.
Ця плита важить 2,9 кг. Але різниця
в 4 чи 2 кг - вона відчувається.
Драганюк відзначає, що військова форма може бути ще кращою,
пошитою за жіночими лекалами, а не "унісекс".
Однак на такі комплекти потрібен час, якого
зараз у військових у зоні бойових дій немає.
Держава почала працювати над військовою формою для жінок.
У робочу групу увійшли представники міноборони,
дві волонтерські ініціативи
та уповноважена президента України з питань безбар'єрності.
Депутатка Київради і волонтерка Ірина Никорак -
одна з учасниць робочої групи.
Ми, власне, почали аналізувати, і зараз
продовжуємо це робити, світовий досвід.
Позаду мене, власне, тут у нас у штабі
дуже багато екземплярів різних форм,
які нам передавали зі Сполучених Штатів Америки, з Франції. Зараз очікуємо, ще з Канади, з Ізраїлю.
Ми намагаємося врахувати передовий
світовий досвід, як вони йшли.
За словами Никорак, наразі тестування у польових умовах проходять вже два прототипи жіночої форми,
третій ще готується. Далі робоча група чекатиме
відгуків від військовослужбовиць.
Нам потрібно її протестувати.
І якщо процес тестування пройде успішно,
ми дійсно отримаємо багато позитивних відгуків,
то далі буде етап затвердження самого лекала.
Як тільки ми допрацюємо ці лекала, ми їх
передаємо до міністерства оборони,
і далі вже буде прийматися рішення про те,
чи можна адаптувати існуючу уніформу,
чоловічу, під жіночу антропометрією, з урахуванням
різних фіксаторів, пом'якшувачі і так далі,
чи буде розроблена польова форма безпосередньо жіноча.
Однак ані представники робочої групи,
ані міністерство оборони не вказують термінів,
коли жінки зможуть отримати від держави
адаптовану військову форму.
Тому військовослужбовицям все ще доводиться вирішувати питання своїми силами або за допомогою волонтерів.
Хоча за словами волонтерки Ксенії Драганюк, іноді для українських жінок поїхати на нульові позиції легше,
ніж попросити щось безкоштовно.
Були випадки, коли дівчата приходять до нас в хаб
і роблять ось так: "Ех, мені б оце".
Дискомфорт попросити є у всіх. Є дівчата, які пишуть
"Я два тижні наважувалася, а можна у вас
попросити форму, будь ласка?"
Я кажу: "Треба". Ми кажемо: "Ви не просите.
Ми з вам розділилися задля спільної мети.
Ви на фронті. Ми в тилу. Ви там працюєте, ми тут працюємо".